[موسيقى]
انظروا العالم تتجه الى تركيا مع اغلاق
الصناديق الاقتراع الحذر يخيم على الهدنه
في غزه والمعابر تعود للعمل مفاوضات وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان تستانف بجده هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تتجه انظار العالم اليوم صوبه تركيا التي
اغلقت فيها قبل قليل صناديق التصويت
بالانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه بعد ان
شهدت اقبالا واسعا حيث يواجه الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان بعد 20 عاما في
السلطه معارضه موحده مدعومه بقاعده شعبيه
واسعه ويترقب الشارع التركي النتيجه
النهائيه بحلول ساعه متاخره من مساء اليوم
الاحد حيث من المتوقع ان تتضح مؤشرات حول
ما اذا كان سيتم اجراء جوله اعاده فاذا لم
يحصل اي مرشحه على اكثر من 50% من الاصوات
سيذهب السباق الرئاسي الى جوله اعاده في
الثامن والعشرين من مايو الجاريه
بعد خمسه ايام من القصف المتبادل بين
الفصائل الفلسطينيه والجيش الاسرائيلي ومع
دخول اتفاق الهدنه حيز التنفيذ يشهد قطاع
غزه هدوءا حذرا متمثلا بعوده الحياه مجددا
الى شوارعه وشواطئه اضافه لفتح تدريجيا
لمعبري بيت حانون وكرم ابو سالم
متمثلا بعوده الحياه اذا مثل ما ذكرنا الى
الشوارع والشواطئ اضافه لفتح المعابر
التجاريه
وللافراد لكن الهدنه في غزه لم تمنع من
وقوع انتهاكات اسرائيليه في مناطق
فلسطينيه اخرى حيث افادت وسائل الاعلام
باصابه شاب برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه بعد
اقتحام البلده القديمه في مدينه نابلس
بالضفه الغربيه الامر الذي تطور الى
اشتباكات متقطعه
من غزه الى السودان الذي يشهد هو الاخر
اقتطالا دخل اصبعه الخامس ففي اخر
التطورات تستانف اليوم الجوله الثانيه من
المفاوضات بين ممثلي الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع في جده وستتركز الاجتماعات على
كيفيه تنفيذ خطط ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وسحب القوات من المناطق المدنيه
وفقا لما نقلت رويترز عن مصدر دبلوماسي
سعودي في غضون ذلك ارتفعت وتيره القصف
الجوي والمضادات والاشتباكات بين جيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في العاصمه
الخرطومه كما سمع دواء انفجارات هزت احياء
اندرمان
بعد ايام من حفل تتويج الملك تشارلز في
بريطانيا استقل وزير خارجيه بابوا غينيا
الجديده من منصبه بسبب تكلفه مشاركه وفي
بلاده في مراسم تتويج الملك كونها جزء من
دول الكوميدي الوزيره المستقيل وجهه
انتقادات واسعه لحكومته التي ارسلت وفدا
مؤلفا من 30 شخصا لمراسم التتويج في وسمه
بنفقات كبيره وصلت ل 50,000
كينيا اي نحو 14 الف دولار لكل فرد من
الوفد كبدل تكاليف سفر واقامه مشددا على
انه كان يجب صرف هذا المبلغ الضخم على
الاعمال الخيريه
نختم من على الصومال التي حلت به كارثه
طبيعيه تسببت بفيضانات ضربت وسط البلاد
ونزوح نحو 200 الف شخص ومقتل ثلاثه
وافقدان العشرات الكارثه جاءت بعد ثعبان
نهر شبيل ماء اجبر سكان بلده بيليدوين في
منطقه حيران على مغادره منازلهم حيث تسببت
الامطار الغزيره بارتفاع منسوب المياه
بشكل حاد في مقاله مسؤولون صوماليون ان
الاعداد قد ترتفع في اي وقت وتاتي هذه
الكارثه عاقبه موجه جفاف قياسيه جعلت
ملايين الصوماليين على شفاء المجاعه وفقا
لتقديرات وارقام امميه
[موسيقى]